what is meaningful conflict and why do
so many screenwriters get this wrong
so meaningful conflict i mean conflict
to me is synonymous with problems so i
remember early in my screenwriting
endeavors i had people sometimes say
your script doesn't have enough conflict
and i was like i don't understand what
that means like i thought conflict just
meant people fighting and arguing you
know or beating up on each other
but then i came to understand that
conflict and problem mean the same thing
so in any story the audience is most
interested and engaged when there's some
kind of problem that someone is actively
trying to resolve that's pretty much
like scene writing 101 story 101 you
always want to be focused on that and
whenever there isn't a problem to be
solved or whenever no one's trying to
solve it even if it exists
audience
engagement and emotional engagement
tends to sag a little bit so meaningful
conflict would just mean conflict that
is really related to the overall goal of
the story you know every story kind of
begins with
something that makes us go oh here's
what needs to be solved here's the
outcome that's being pursued that
hopefully i'm emotionally invested i
want to see them reach that outcome
so
meaningful conflict would be conflict in
scenes then which have to do with that
outcome and and how is it going trying
to get to that outcome because you could
have conflict that doesn't really relate
to the larger story goal
that wouldn't be so meaningful it would
just be conflict for the sake of
conflict so ideally it's conflict that
matters to the story and you might also
have like a b story like there's a
conflicted relationship with somebody
who's the ally or the love interest or
something and so you might have
meaningful conflict that's advancing the
b story it doesn't always have to be
about whatever that kind of a story goal
is but to me the most important thing is
you do need constant conflict which
means constant problems and it should be
meaningful to whatever we're all there
to try to see work out
what about when people put
too much conflict right away i mean i'm
thinking of let's say i was really
dating myself with the movie staying
alive it was great to see
it's such a great film i just have to go
um when john travolta's character is
sort of strutting down the street and
he's like he bumps into sylvester
stallone's character and it kind of
shows like okay this is new york city
and it's very like tight and you're up
against all these people it's a little
bit contentious but it works because it
kind of shows that but then sometimes
i've seen films where there's just two
there's like an argument that doesn't
belong in there it's right away how do
you balance
my feeling about the beginning of a
movie is that you're mostly trying to
get the audience to understand the main
character and their status quo life and
emotionally
get invested in who they are and what
their basic life situation is before the
big problem has emerged which will then
occupy the rest of the story that big
problem tends to emerge as the catalyst
or the inciting event or inciting
incident you know maybe about 12 pages
in if you use like to save the cat page
count once that thing happens that rocks
their world and then sets them on a
mission ultimately for the rest of the
story to resolve whatever happened at
that catalyst prior to the catalyst
you're just introducing the audience to
the main character and their world
and you're hopefully getting them
understanding enough about that
character that they can start to feel
they know them and they know their
situation writers often have issues with
this where they don't really do that
very well they don't stay with the main
character and take the time to kind of
illustrate what their current life is
and
make them emotionally accessible to the
audience and make us have a reason to
want to follow them that that term save
the cat the idea if they save a cat in
the first 10 pages we'll care about them
is kind of a half joking but but the
idea that we
we get invested in the character for
some reason that the audience
is led to by the writer give us a reason
to care because we tend to not care
about some stranger in a movie unless
you make us care so that's like almost
the writer's first and foremost job make
us care and so it starts the beginning
so
to me the opening scenes of a movie the
first 10 pages or so they should have
conflict in them because every scene
should have conflict but that conflict
should be just the normal conflicts of
that character's
everyday life kind of up until before
the catalyst hits even a move even a
movie like saving private ryan which
opens with the most biggest conflict you
could imagine you know storming omaha
beach
ultimately that's just illustrating what
tom hanks's life was right before the
catalyst of the movie the catalyst being
he gets the order that you've got to go
save private ryan right that sets in
motion the real story problem for the
rest of the movie and the outcome that
we all get invested in prior to that
we're just seeing well what's captain
miller's life and his unit's life like
before they get that order how do we get
up to speed with who he is and what he's
dealing with and what's going on in his
life right now he's got a very special
version of that but that's kind of the
same thing for everyone for every movie
so
you can have conflict you should have
conflict but sometimes people want to
open with something really big where
they're already launching the story on
page one in other words like the
catalyst event is happening at the very
beginning before we have any idea who is
who or what the world of the story is
and i think that tends to be a mistake
because the audience needs some time
to get up to speed and invested first
right and even like let's say big little
lies you have reese witherspoon and it's
very you know sort of manicured
you know
it seems more pampered life but there's
these little
dilemmas throughout like with the
carpool and going to the school and
someone's in her way and she's not
getting what she wants from her child
and so you you see these little mini
conflicts being set up even though it
doesn't seem like the same as as a war
scene yeah conflicts but not the one big
conflict that's going to drive the rest
of the the story from that point forward
and in a series like that you're also
doing that times four different
characters i think where each one of
those characters gets some of those
scenes in the beginning that makes us go
okay here's this person here's their
life situation here's the basic
conflicts for them here's their basic
personality their basic desires
and what's in the way of those desires
nothing huge has happened to rock their
world and start the story but i get who
they are i get who nicole kidman is i
get who shaylene woodley is etc
so yeah and that's part of why writing a
pilot
can be harder because you have to set up
multiple characters and you have to do
it quickly you have to find the right
way to make the audience go i get who
they are and i kind of am intrigued and
i kind of care about them a little i
want to see
where life is going for them whereas in
a movie you usually only have one main
character and you've got like 10 12
pages to just do it for them you don't
have to do it for anybody else in fact
you shouldn't be trying to spend time on
scenes about other characters in the
first 10 pages in my view because the
whole goal is to get us caring about the
main character because we're going to
subjectively experience the rest of the
story through their point of view so
it's not about showing us these other
people what's going on with them it's
about get us inside their world and
their psychology looking out through
their eyes as they live their life
right and so with staying alive going
back to john travolta checks in any
messages and he's in this
sort of like i don't know weekly motel
or whatever that in new york city where
he's a struggling actor dancer and of
course the guy's like no
so it just shows again this guy's okay
another week humble and sort of broke
and you that kind of sets off his world
because that's basically before he meets
the final hughes character yeah it's
this is my normal life and here are the
problems in my normal life
that are just the status quo situation
that and it makes you care about him
because he's got this kind of undeserved
misfortune you always feel for the
underdog the person that wants something
they can't have that they're working
toward but nobody cares so that's a
classic way to make an audience
want to invest in the main character in
those opening pages
you